Wait.
Go. Go.
I was eight years old when I left earth
Do you want me to drive?
No. I'll drive.
Figure out how to put it in backwards.
Welcome back,
everyone, it's Charlie. Big surprise,
James Gunn and Marvel dropped
a brand new guardians of the Galaxy
3 trailer video to celebrate tickets
going on sale.
They go on sale Monday,
but they're like six
other trailers that are dropping next week
and some of them are coming on Monday.
So they probably wanted to drop this
a couple of days early.
There's a bunch of new footage,
Easter eggs that will break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
Also do a giveaway for movie tickets.
All yet to enter is be a subscriber
in post.
Your favorite moment
from the trailers on the video.
Just starting at the beginning
of the trailer footage,
this wooden looking Marvel Studios logo.
If you couldn't tell like
the white version of it
is meant to be a reference to Peter
Quill's tape player from the first movie,
that ship wound up being destroyed.
But obviously,
like I said, they're referencing things
from that first movie we get the new shot
of Rocket in front of this fridge here.
The funny Easter egg here is that
it seems like he's drinking space milk
because the writing on the fridge
behind him
zoom in enhanced is in the Cree language
and it translates to milk
because the main villain of Guardians of
the Galaxy three is the high evolutionary.
This is also meant to be a bit of a deep
cut Easter egg for Bova one of the high
evolutionary creations
who was a huge part of Scarlet Witch
and Quicksilver's origin story.
Also, the whole idea you get milk
from cows were in space.
So they're space cows.
One of the space cows in the Marvel
Universe is Boba,
but originally his main base was on planet
Earth, which is how
he runs into Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch
when they were children.
One of his earliest creations was Boba.
There was also an Easter egg for her
during one division in the supermarket
during the opening credits,
because that series was all about Scarlet
Witch with a little bit of Quicksilver.
So Magneto is Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver's father.
He has them with his wife, Magda,
but after they're born,
afraid of what will happen to Magneto
because he is Magneto.
Everyone wants to kill him
and he's kind of dangerous himself.
Magda flees to mount wundagore nearby
with the twins who are still newborns.
The high evolutionary base
used to be on Mount.
wundagore
there was an Easter egg for Mount Wonder
Go during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness.
That was the place where Ch'thon
built the Darkhold Temple in the MCU.
So Magnet flees to Mount Wundagore to visit the high evolutionary
asks for sanctuary for the twins,
which he denies.
Bova then gives them to the Maximoff,
which is why Quicksilver
Scarlet Witch have the last name Maximoff.
They're Wanda and Pietro Maximoff.
They don't carry the ledger name
for their real father.
There's a scene, a Peter Quill,
flying with a couple other ships.
It seems like he's working either
with other guardians
and other smaller ships
or they have some larger operation.
This might be when they're getting ready
to face the high evolutionary
or getting ready to escape.
The way they cut
the trailers is a little misleading.
The way they cut the footage,
it makes it seem like they're escaping
this giant space celestial anus.
But they play the joke about waiting,
waiting, waiting, and then, boom,
into action. The big call to action.
Throughout the entire trailer,
you see the younger version of Gomorrah
inside the cockpit of the Milano
getting ready to pilot this part
of the ship when they spring into action.
As he actually starts piloting the ship,
it seems like these giant arms around her
activate the ship.
Kind of like you would activate a mech
like she's operating the ship with these
arms instead of a traditional console
like you would the normal ships
that they've flown in the past.
Also love the joke here with Drax,
with the way they're cutting
the anticipation,
just building and building and building
into action later in the trailer.
But when they flash to Drax,
his character, he's eating snacks.
I think that's meant to be a joke.
Call back to him eating snacks, pretending
to be invisible in Infinity War.
I've mastered the ability of
standing so incredibly still
that I become invisible to the eye.
Watch.
You're eating his argument,
but my movement
so slow
and it's imperceptible.
You see Rocket putting on their new
Guardians of the Galaxy uniforms.
These are obviously based on
the annihilation versions of the uniforms,
which they wore in the storyline,
where this version of the team
that you've seen in all the Guardians
movies assembled for the first time.
The funny coincidence about that team,
too, in that storyline is that during
that Adam Warlock was a big part of it,
like he is during the third movie here
and he winds up working with them,
joining the Guardians briefly.
A lot of theories about him
eventually joining the future
version of the Guardians
that do they cycle the roster
because of the teaser.
So many characters
dying during this movie.
Not all the guardians are supposed to die,
but this is meant to be
the last ride, quote unquote,
for this particular team.
So at least one of them
will probably die in
then a couple of others
might just go away,
but there will be more Guardians
teams in future movies if there aren't
more direct Guardians movies themselves,
like Guardians four.
I'll talk about those potential
different Guardians rosters later.
In the video
you see the new Chad version of Groot
getting ready to pilot this smaller ship
nearby them.
Really cool scene of Groot,
hulking out with Star-Lord going crazy.
The high evolutionary is based.
I don't know if he's going to get
any bigger, like any taller, so to speak.
James going to explain.
He's meant to be kind of
like the son of the original groups.
Like the Original Groot isn't coming back.
This isn't meant to be like him
being reborn into a new body.
This root is meant to have a completely
different personality from the Groot
in the first Guardians movie.
Also kind of seems like he's
addicted to video games.
Really loved the classic Game Boy
Easter Egg in the holiday special too.
The spring into action.
Their ship leaves
the high evolutionary station here.
I've made all kinds of theories about what
this actually is because it looks
like the remains of a giant space creature
like this.
This giant scene that looks like a giant
celestial size space anus.
That's part of the joke of the Guardians
of the Galaxy.
Movies like you have a celestial head
of nowhere, which they actually own now.
They bought that from the collector
during the Guardians of the Galaxy
Christmas special.
We had a celestial head.
There's a dead celestial sticking out
of the Indian Ocean on Earth currently.
Now we have a giant celestial.
The scene of rocket cocking the giant gun
also meant to be a callback
to the first movie.
There are a couple of direct shots
that are meant to look exactly
like the shots from the first movie.
This scene of rocket
fighting on top of shoulder
obviously meant to be a reference to them
doing the exact same thing
in the first Guardians
movie is the end of the trilogy.
So naturally
there'll be a lot of moments in this movie
that reference all the previous Guardians
of the Galaxy moments.
It seems like they want to show
Star-Lord slowly winning game more over.
I don't know if that's going to happen
by the end of the movie
because I don't think
either one of them are going to die.
The new fuzzy character beneath them that
they're protecting is just named Blurb.
He's meant to be like Rocket, like one of
the other high evolutionary experiments.
We get to see the high evolutionary
use his powers in present day.
It seems like
we'll see a couple of time jumps
because we know we're going to flashback
to Sea Rocket's origin story.
In part of the whole deal
with the high evolutionary
is that he continually tries
to upgrade himself,
modifying himself like he's modifying
these other human animal hybrids.
We get a bunch new Adam warlock footage.
We see him
flying across a bunch of debris.
He has a bunch of comic book powers.
I don't know
how many of his comic book powers
they're going to give the movie version
of the character.
He is meant to be one of the most powerful
Marvel characters, though
James Gunn
also confirmed a lot of my theories
in that
they're playing the character
in this movie
a little bit the way they played vision
in Avengers Age of Ultron, born yesterday.
Like all those kinds of jokes, like he's
basically a baby
who was just born, so he doesn't
really understand people that much.
And a lot of his arc in
the movie is meant to flow with the themes
of his original comic book origin story,
where he was
originally created to be a weapon
and then slowly learns over time
to figure things out on his own.
It kind of balances out.
Usually
when people think of the character,
they think of him
as being a good character.
But he's gone both ways
and there's the whole major's personality.
I'm not expecting them
to do a whole lot of major stuff
in the Marvel movies, at least right now,
but they could always do that
in the future.
In the comics,
he was created by a separate group
on Earth,
but eventually he left them
and just traveled the galaxy, trying
to learn new things,
learning about cultures, people, society.
Those travels took him to the high
evolutionary counter
earth, where high evolutionary formed
a bargain with him to help get rid of man
beast, which was one of his human animal
hybrid creations that have gone crazy
in as part of that high evolutionary
upgraded him with the soul gem
also when Adam Warlock went to counter
Earth to try and deal with man
bees, the people that were living there
that he was trying to save
gave him the name Adam
Groot versus Adam Warlock.
This is a reunion scene
between Rocket and Lyla,
who was his girlfriend in the comics.
She's meant to be another one of the high
evolutionary experiments just like him.
Then they had that funny scene of Peter
Quill on Counter Earth.
Remember?
This is meant to be Counter Earth.
That's why they're all the human
animal hybrids around them.
So it looks like this freakish eighties
looking version of Earth
that the high evolutionary
is just experimenting with.
And they had the whole joke
about how he doesn't know how to drive
a car, like he's a great spaceship pilot,
but he never learned to drive a car
because he left Earth
when he was eight years old.
In this play,
the moment for comedy with Nebula
getting really pissed off and I'm like,
Do you want me to drive?
Peter Quill confirmed. Terrible driver.
I love the attention to detail here too.
Like you see the beads on the car seats.
That's
how much detail the high evolutionary
is going in to in this experiment here.
You also look at some of these details
in the costumes that the characters
are wearing, too,
like they're wearing very human looking,
very American eighties types of clothes,
like the girl's backpack, her dress.
You zoom in, enhance on the street. Sign
here, too.
There's a couple aliens on the sign.
Just in terms of the new team members,
like who's going to be on the new roster
after this movie?
We already know Cragen
Probably going to survive
and become a main team member,
but he's already kind of on the team,
like he's been on the team for a while.
Peter Quill will probably continue
as Star-Lord Groot in his new Kaiju form.
Cosmo The Space
Dog may be the new version of Gamora.
I don't think she's going to die,
but she might not continue with a team
like she might go off on her own.
Nebula will continue, like
we'll see more nebula stuff in the future.
We already know Drax is not continuing,
but Adam
Warlock was a big member of the team
in the Annihilation Conquest storyline
and that's where they had these versions
of the uniforms
that you see in this trailer.
So early theory
he winds up joining the team.
Nova was a member of the team
in the comics
and they have been talking about
introducing the character in the MCU.
There was a deleted scene in Avengers
Infinity War
that introduced the character.
I've already gotten a bunch of videos
about that.
Right now
they're talking about doing him in either
a special presentation or a Disney
Plus series, not a movie.
So we'll see where they wind up
introducing the character.
There's Beta Ray Bill.
He was also on the team
for a while in the comics
and there have been a bunch of beta ray
bill deleted scenes already in the movies.
They're a couple longshot characters too,
but people have been asking me
because they're introducing X-Men
to the MCU, especially after Secret Wars.
So like Kitty Pryde
was a big part of the team in the comics.
She even got married to Star-Lord
for a little while, but I'm not expecting
her to join the team.
Captain
Marvel could wind up joining the team,
but they want to use the character in so
many other different scroll based stories.
Nick Fury stuff.
I'm not expecting her to join the team
either.
Moon, Dragon, Quasar and Agent Venom
were also members of the team
at different periods, but like,
I don't expect Agent Venom, for instance,
to come into the MCU
because we already have the Eddie
Brock version of Venom,
and I don't think it's going to change
any time soon.
It is about it.
Any other Easter eggs or references
during the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
There'll be a couple more trailers
dropping in the next couple of days.
They're supposed to be a new Spider-Man
Across the Spider-Verse trailer,
another new secret invasion
trailer in a blue Beetle trailer
on the DC side of things.
Of course, I'll do videos for everything.
Everyone click here for that
other brand new Guardians of the Galaxy
three trailer and click here for that
new secret invasion trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.